[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but it can be used against infantry and
this weapon is so
precise you know it's uh they guide the
missiles we he killed two guys beside me
okay uh right there you know and it's so
powerful and precise and dangerous and
it makes sense because the country is
more modern than Afghanistan tourists
and so it makes sense that we have such
Advanced Weaponry on both sides so but
at the same time it's terrible you know
it's terrible you can be you should see
the the wounds you know of the soldiers
it's uh you know yeah
the other day there was this uh Medics
giving us you know latest feedbacks
about the the front lines you know on
some places and one of the pictures and
I've seen that kind of scenes before
um he did the guy didn't have any like
mouth you know is this part the jaw was
like not there anymore it was all
bleeding and like pretty much after of
the the face was not there anymore all
blue uh all blood and I was asked and I
asked is this guy I still alive he said
yes he's still alive and but he's gonna
have no job that guy he's gonna be like
just half of the face you know because
of all these explosion that he's offered
and yesterday I talked to an Americans
who was giving us supplies for the front
line coming and that guy uh has
conclusion conclusion you know he's like
he cannot hear from one side yeah
because of these massive bombs that were
that landed you know beside his places
in zapology in south of Ukraine yeah so
and and while these two guys that that
died
um in front of you the the the other day
they they uh one
um they're friends of yours
uh that friend I would say but uh
Brothers in Arms you know people I knew
briefly and I remember one of them was
speaking French like I do and uh verse
like like just basic French but he was
Ukrainian members huh he was Ukrainian
yeah he was Ukrainian he wasn't an
experienced Soldier and but he had a
good attitude that's typical from the U
Prince you know they're they're very
courageous you know many of them they
don't have the experience as soldiers
because it's it's conscription you know
so they're sent to the front with
minimal training because that's the
situation so he went there into the
trench and he was smiling and being a
nice guy you know and but he's not
experienced so that's what happened in
in Warfare it's very like Wars I would
say
you know typically in more people either
underestimate the danger or overestimate
the danger so you see a lot of people
panicking or being careless in war you
see you see being professional usually
is being in the middle no big
professional soldiers we would
experience gonna be
I would say not careless but not
panicking at everything so they're going
to be like in the middle but you see a
lot of the inexperienced Soldier when
nothing happens let's see nothing
happens for three days a week or two
weeks
and you're not experienced you might
think oh nothing happens it's easy and
then out of nowhere you're going to be
killed by Advanced weapons you know
something and these weapons are so
Advanced something what was going on
with these guys I mean because in a
moment there can you just walk me
through that that that that what what
happened
yeah uh in in that instance these guys
were TD we called TD Turtle defense so
that means basically militias you know
uh with minimal training but very
courageous again very courageous but no
experience so in that particular
situation uh we went to uh I was doing
snipers Mission you know and I I was
telling the ukrainians commander that
this position this trench in in the
forest was a bad position because it was
too obvious you know it's it's you know
you don't put a sniper on top of let's
say a church you know and because it's
obvious you know so it's a target for
for everybody so they were putting such
a trench position
in in the obvious uh place you know so I
told him it's a very bad idea to move
this position so first mistake the
position was obvious so I went there
and there was this uh this uh trench you
know the size pretty much I would say of
a bed so it's a pretty small trench you
know with the protection of red
protection because with a roof basically
and and I went there uh with my sniper
rifle and my intent was to grab
information about the latest what they
saw you know these two guys you know
these two and the trench and uh in the
surrounding where are the tanks where
the did you see infantry approaching
that way blah blah blah you know to to
get some information you know because
there's nothing like having information
from the people at the front you know
latest information so
I went there and I was protecting myself
behind you know the amounts of of dirt
you know because of the transit yeah
this amount of dirt I was protecting
myself with my sniper rifle being very
very careful because I knew that
they were enemies in some that direction
you know and so I was protecting myself
putting cam sticks and being very you
know careful and this two guy maybe they
were bored in their trench they went out
of the trench
and they were like there was no war you
know we were in the woods some some kind
of cover which was
okay you know a bit hidden from the
enemy but not ideal you know so I told
them go back into the trench did you
know how close the Russians were at this
point yeah they were uh pretty much the
closest one were maybe still far you
know they they were tanks lots of lots
of tanks in that position maybe 1.5 the
closest and the first three but
thousands of things they were everywhere
you can see them like you just you just
poke your heads out of the trench and
then you can okay oh thank thank and
these two guys at that point I was in
the forest you know and I knew there
were tanks in that direction but I
didn't know where exactly you know and
my intent was to to kill them with
anti-tank weapon the job no I had the
job and I had to learn on YouTube by the
way I want to use that that system but
that's right I heard that man so yeah so
so the guy went out of the trench
started smoking and it was in the
morning so we have to understand that
thermal vision thermal equipment you
know from Russian side or any site
especially on the morning on cold let's
say when it's a bit cold you know when
it's fresh in the morning they see more
clearly you know the bodies and the heat
spot moving around you know so it's very
dangerous in the morning especially when
there's no wind when there's uh you know
when it's you know quiet you know in the
morning so it was in the morning they
went out on the trench I told them go
back into the trench you know that's
very dangerous what you're doing is it
the perfect way to get killed you know
and my teammate which is um which is a
Canadian
he's staying to the trench you know I
will remember that he's like okay I have
no experience that was this we're saying
yeah so I'm gonna listen to you Wally
you know so I told him I know war is
boring because that's War you know we
have to stay you have to do sometimes
your job is to do boring stuff and now
your job is to stay in the trench and be
ready in case infantry enemy is
approaching and we have to shoot them
basically so you hide and you do nothing
else that's boring you know but that's
all war is no so we stayed there like
board and in the mod you know which is
rifle and I I told him that's very good
but then the other two guys were like
going out of the trench smoking being
like a bit cold you know and I don't
even go back go back go back and they
will not listen but I was like the
Tank's all right there you know where
are they and they were while I was
asking this this question and they move
by the edge of the forest maybe 10
meters away you know
and for me it was enough and I was like
okay come back a minute that's
never do that I was like almost like
screaming you know
I come back you know and then they were
like okay okay let's come back blah blah
blah and then they came back
and they stayed maybe two three seconds
at the end of the house where they it
was no branches almost so standing they
went back and I was thinking that's very
bad you know that's very dangerous what
they're doing so just in case
some enemy spotted us no I'm gonna move
away 15 meters just as you know
precautions you know in case
and I always camouflage with my netting
and everything that's like a sniper you
know so I move around in some other
direction 15 meters away I would say
about and I was with my binos all with
my Nets and now I was looking for the
tanks I knew that there were some tanks
in that place and I I was looking for
things and then it took maybe 10 seconds
huge explosion you know very powerful
you know you I remember exactly how it
looked like I saw the shred those like
you know like lasers you know in front
of me just in the smokes and the smoke
you it's hard to explain but it's
it was like the smoke of death you know
you feel death coming taking people you
know if it's kind of it's very like I
would say it's hard to explain what you
feel death is is there no taking Souls
no basically and I was so shocked I
couldn't like half of my head was you
know in concussion you know so and then
you right away that was very bad you
know
that's why I crawl back to the trench I
was so shaking because on one side I
could not hear anything anymore no and I
went under protection beside the trench
my colleague you know uh the Canadian
was still in the trench shaking as hell
you know but nothing he had nothing you
know not a single instructional nothing
just shake no and I look left and maybe
I would say six meters away six seven
meters away there were smokes in the air
and debris and piece of woods you know
and I would say seven meters away there
was this guy Ukrainian the one who was
speaking French a bit very nice guy very
very nice guy young one maybe 25 years
old I would say and he he both of his
leg were gone uh one leg I I think was
all messed up you know my mermaid is not
like perfect I think at least the two
legs were missing and I think one of
this arm was missing but all this
uniform was twisted and bloody and he
was not moving in where he was on his
back not moving was dead obviously and
then the other one the other Soldier was
maybe two or three meters away from me
you know right there right beside me
and and it looked like so much like a
war war movie it was like perfectly
stage move movie scene you know the guy
darling on his back dead the smokes the
the woods laying on the on the you know
on the soil on the ground and then this
guy was still alive the older one and it
was on his side one of his leg was
caught no bleeding
uh one of his harm was either cut I
don't remember exactly what he was in a
bad shape as maybe F no maybe I don't
remember exactly but I think it was one
arm not there and it was
full of blood and in a very bad State
and he was still bleeding he wasn't
looking towards me but he wasn't towards
me but he was towards me not looking at
me was inside were closing was deep
deeply like breathing like
and it was like
he was telling himself what the hell
happened you know it was like so shock
and then maybe five ten seconds after
that he stopped breeding like like a
balloon like deflating and he died that
way like two three meters away from me
and and then it was I think I think it
was a guide on the side because it was
so precise you know it went right beside
the two guys
and add nothing except this
damage to the ear and 24 hours after
that I was good it was good to go
surprisingly I don't understand how
about 24 hours after that I recovered
from this no but the same day I could
not hear from one side
[Music]